GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY IT IS TUESDAY
JUNE NINETEENTH.
AND WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM
BUT WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
I WILL LET EVERYONE KNOW THAT
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. SIX NINETY
ONE LARA AND ITEM NUMBER FOUR S.
B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE HUESO HAVE
BEEN.
PULLED FROM OUR HEARING TODAY.
SO WE'LL START WITH DOCTOR PAN
ITEM NUMBER.
SIX S. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR GOOD
MORNING NAY.
GOOD MORNING MORNINGS CHAIR
MEMBERS --
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO PRESENT S.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR A BILL
THAT THE DIRECTS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY
GROUP TO STUDY THE PROBLEM OF
THE SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION
THROUGH INTERNET BASED SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS.
A DRAFT THE MODEL STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR SUCH PLATFORMS HELP MITIGATE
SPREAD FALSE INFORMATION THROUGH
THOSE PLATFORMS.
I INTRODUCED S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BECAUSE OF A CLEAR
ISSUE AND PROBLEM WHEN IT COMES
THE SPREAD OF FIRE FALSE
INFORMATION THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
[inaudible]
CERTAINLY [inaudible]
SPREADING --
THE ISSUES ABOUT THE FLAT EARTH
THOUGH ARE --
AND MAY SEEM SOMEWHAT AMUSING
BUT WHEN IT STARTS MOVING TO
THINGS LIKE HOLOCAUST DENIAL --
PRODUCTION AND IMMUNIZATION
RATES BECAUSE FOR CONTINUED RA
REPETITION THAT VACCINES CAUSE
AUTISM.
GOING TO ACTUALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENED.
MORE RECENTLY WHERE I YOU HAVE
PEOPLE DENYING --
SHOOTINGS THAT HAPPENED AND
PLACES LIKE PARK LAND AND AND
YEAH AND ACTUALLY I ACTUALLY UP
--
WIND ALSO PRONE TO MANIPULATION
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY GET TO A
COMPETING PROTESTS AND I AND YOU
STAND UP THROUGH MANIPULATION.
SPREAD OF FLUFF FALSE
INFORMATION THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
THAT FACT WE KNOW THAT --
MANY PEOPLE GET THEIR NEWS
PRIMARILY FROM SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOW WHAT THE SCIENCE SHOW
WALMART TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN ON
SCIENCE MAGAZINE REPORTED THAT.
WHEN THEY INVESTIGATED
DIFFERENTIAL DIFFUSION OF ALL
THE FAIR BY TRUE AND FALSE NEWS
STORIES DISTRIBUTE TWITTER
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SIX IN?
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THEY
FOUND THAT FALSE INFORMATION
FALSEHOODS WOULD DIFFUSE
SIGNIFICANT FARTHER FASTER
DEEPER MORE BROADLY.
THEN TRUE INFORMATION IN ALL
CATEGORIES OF INFORMATION AND
FACT THE SPREAD OF FALSE
INFORMATION SPREAD TWICE AS
QUICKLY AND TWICE AS FAR.
ARE ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
SINCE SOCIAL MEDIA WEBSITES ARE
THE PLATFORMS FOR WHICH SOUGHT
FALSE INFORMATION SPREADS IT'S
GOING TO BECOME MORE IMPORTANT
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS
HAPPENING.
SEVERAL COMPANIES ARE COMING UP
WITH PLANS TO TRY TO MITIGATE
THE SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION
--
BUT PUBLIC SHOULD KNOW WHAT
THOSE PLANS ARE AND THEY KNOW IF
THEY'RE WORKING.
BY ASKING SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
LET'S KNOW IF THEY HAVE A PLAN
OF WHAT THOSE PLANS ARE WE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW NEWS.
SPREADS CONTINUE WORKING GROUP
TO STUDY STRATEGIC PLAN MILES BE
THE FIRST STEP IN WORKING TO
SLOW THE SPREAD OF FALSE
INFORMATION OPEN THE FUTURE WILL
BE A BETTER BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC FROM.
HARM THAT CAN COME FROM THAT
CAUSED BY UNTRUE STORIES THIS
REALLY BECOMES AT THE FOUNDATION
OF DEMOCRACY.
AND CERTAINLY --
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WHETHER WHAT.
I ACTUALLY LIMITING WHAT ANYONE
WANTS TO SAY OUR CANCER
INCLUDING EVEN.
SAYING FALSE INFORMATION --
HOWEVER I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S
HOW WE ARE PROMOTING HOW THAT'S
BEING POTENTIALLY BEING
DISSEMINATED IN FACT EVEN OVER
--
TRUTH OUT ACCURATE AND TRUE
INFORMATION AND THAT
UNDERSTANDING IT'S GONNA BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT OUR
SOCIETY MAQRIZI EXPECT WE ASK
WHEN I BUT THANK YOU YOU HAVE
WITH ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL.
ALRIGHT CNN IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SIDE IT THAT BAD APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS A STUDY BILL AND AND
REALLY TAKING A GOOD LOOK AT
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO
WRESTLE WITH IN OUR SOCIETY BUT
WE ALSO HAVE SOME VERY.
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS WITH RESPECT
TO FREE SPEECH AND THOSE ARE
DELICATE WHEN WE DEAL WITH THE
INTERNET AND DISSEMINATION OF OF
INFORMATION SO I THINK I DO
THINK WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL IN.
HOW WE SEEK TO RESTRICT
INFORMATION EVEN IF WE FIND IT
OFFENSIVE OR DIFFICULT OR OR
UNCOMFORTABLE?
SO I APPRECIATE YOU WAITING IN
THIS DIRECTION BUT WE'LL WE'LL
SEE WHERE THIS GOES ON
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE OKAY.
AND WILL TAKE UP A VOTE ONCE WE
HAVE QUITE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU AND THE SOUND
OF IT YOU MAY CLOSE UP OKAY WELL
AT FOR I APPRECIATE THAT AND
THEN FORM SUCH A STUDY --
WOULD CERTAINLY THIS IS NOT.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS NOT THE
CORE OF OUR NATION AND OUR
SOCIETY AND WE WON'T BE SURE
THAT THAT IS PROTECTED.
WE ALSO NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW
INFORMATION IS BEING ASSEMBLY
OCCLUDING MISINFORMATION AND
THAT AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU.
AND WE JUST SAW SENATOR DODD.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR SENATORS
WILL DODD [inaudible]
AND LARA.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
.
SENATOR WORK WE'RE GOOD ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. B..
TEN SEVENTY SEVEN AND WE ARE
STILL OPERATING AS SUBCOMMITTEE.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR
BILL.
APOLOGIZE THAT I'M LATE THE
ASSEMBLY ELEVATOR PRETTY BUSY
TODAY.
THE STAIRS ARE GOOD.
FOR WHAT TOOK THE STAIRS IN THE
MORNING AND THAT'S MY POINT FOR
THE DAY BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN FOR MY HEALTH.
I THINK THAT IF IT BIT FOR
FATHER'S DAY SO.
YOU GOT A UNIT WHERE THOU GOT TO
USE YEAH [inaudible]
ALRIGHT WELL MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OPERA YOUR CONSIDERATION
I HAVE BEFORE YOU SEND A BILL.
TEN SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
UPDATE AND ENHANCE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS AND PRODUCE A MORE
REASONABLE BIDDING EXPERIENCE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S SUBCONTRACTORS.
CURRENT LAW MANDATES INSURANCE
COVERAGE HELD BY CONTRACTING
PARTIES TO BE DISCLOSED TO
BIDDERS DURING THE BIDDING
PROCESS FOR ALL RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NO SIMILAR
MANDATE FOR COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL OR PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS AND AS A RESULT
SUBCONTRACTING BIDDERS ARE OFTEN
LEFT IN THE DARK.
FORCED TO BE WITHOUT KNOWING THE
TRUE COSTS A MEAN KERWIN
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROJECTS
OWNERS INSURANCE POLICY.
THESE DISCLOSURES INCLUDE
EXCLUSIONS.
TERM OF COVERAGE AND THE MOUNT A
PRIMA CONTRIBUTIONS BEING
REQUIRED.
ALL VITAL COMPONENTS OF
INSURANCE POLICY AND FACTORS
THAT CONTRACTORS WHO RELY ON IN
CRAFTING A BIT.
IT'S VERY COSTLY FOR CONTRACTORS
TO MODIFY DETAILED BIDS THAT MAY
HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO ACCOUNT
FOR UNFORESEEN COSTS FROM AND
INSURANCE POLICIES DEFICIENCIES.
BUT THAT'S WHAT MANY OF OUR
STATES GENERAL CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS ARE FACED WITH
THE UNDER THIS CURRENT PROCESS.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY SEVEN REQUIRES
COMMERCIAL PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT OWNERS TO PROVIDE FULL
AND ACCURATE INSURANCE POLICY
INFORMATION TO CONTRACTORS WHO
ARE BIDDING ON THEIR JOBS.
JUST OF THOSE OPERATING THE
RESENT THAT RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WILL HAVE DONE FOR
YEARS WHICH WITH MUCH SUCCESS.
ADDITIONALLY SPT AND SEVENTY
SEVEN CLOSES LOOPHOLES IN
CURRENT LAN BELIEVE MANY OF OUR
SUB AND GENERAL CONTRACTORS
HOLDING THE BAG FOR LIABILITY
THAT SHOULD RIGHTFULLY BE
COVERED BY THE PROJECTS RAP
INSURANCE POLICY.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
AMERICAN SUBCULTURES A SUB
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND THEN UNION
ROOFING CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
AND HAS WIDESPREAD INDUSTRY
SUPPORT.
WITH ME TODAY SKIP DOM ON BEHALF
OF AMERICA SUB CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ALONG
WITH DAVE STEP CO.
A CONSTITUENT OF MINE AND A
ROOFING SUBCONTRACTOR.
AND AT THIS POINT AT HAND IT
OVER TO MISTER DHAMI FOR HIS
TESTIMONY I THANK YOU SO YOUR
FIRST WITNESS AND THIS BILL HAS
RECOMMENDATIONS OF SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES THANK YOU SIR MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'LL BE CONCISE.
TECHIES GET DAHMER BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN SUB CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION.
FIRST AND FOREMOST THIS BILL
REALLY FOLLOWS THE TREND THAT
WAS A STEP THAT STARTED LAST
YEAR WITH THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KELLY ARROWS
TWELVE TWENTY THREE THAT
ESTABLISHED PHONE TIMELY
DISCLOSURE PAYMENTS.
BY PROJECT DONORS TO THE
CONTRACTORS THEY KNOW THAT THE
MONEY IS THERE WAITING FOR THEM
TO BE PAID WITH --
AND SECONDLY THE BILL
ESSENTIALLY.
GOES TOWARD TRANSPARENCY AND
FULL DISCLOSURE IN A TIMELY
FASHION OF ALL THE INFORMATION
MY SUBCONTRACTORS NEED IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
BID AND AT WHAT AMOUNT.
THE BILL DOES NOT HARM ANYBODY
IN THE PROCESS IT'S GOOD STATE
POLICY TO HAVE FALLEN INTO
TRANSPARENT DISCLOSURES.
AND IT DOES NOT SHIFT LIABILITY
IS THE VERY LATE OPPOSITION
ASSERTS --
SO WE WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU EXPLICITLY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH MY NAME IS DOCTOR RONALD
CONSTANT.
IN I AM THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNION WITHIN
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION.
AND WE ARE THE CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
MY ASSOCIATION IS COMPRISED OF
UNION AFFILIATED COMMERCIAL
ROOFING CONTRACTORS DOMICILED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
KNOWING THAT YOUR TIME IS VERY
VALUABLE I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
OVER THE REMAINING PORTION OF A
HARD TIME FOR THE PRESENTATION
TO MY COLLEAGUE TO THE RIGHT.
MISTER DAVE STEPH CHO WHO IS A
MEMBER OF MY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
AND IS ALSO THE CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER OF EBERHARDT RIFFING IN
VAN NUYS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND IN THIS COMMITTEE
WE DON'T SHARE TIME BUT IT.
WHO ELSE MIGHT? TO PRESENT US
EXACT.
THANK YOU --
THANK YOU ALL.
AND GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DAVE
STUFF CON WITH EVERHART RIFFING
LOCATED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY EMPLOYING TWO HUNDRED
UNION EMPLOYEES.
AND PAST PRESIDENT CURRENT
DIRECTOR THE ROOFING CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND A CURRENT DIRECTOR THE UNION
ROOFING CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
WHO IS ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AS YOU JUST HEARD.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU
BRIEFLY AS A A STORY PERSONAL
STORY FROM MY COMPANY IS THIS IS
THE PART OF THE COMPANY?
THAT I MOSTLY DEAL WITH --
LITIGATION INSURANCE ISSUES
WORKERS COMP ISSUES.
A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HIRES A GENERAL CONTRACTOR.
THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR
SUBCONTRACTS TO ME AND I AM ROLE
IN THE SIT PROGRAM.
THE PROJECT GETS DONE IN FIVE
YEARS LATER THE OWNER SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
FILED A CLAIM AGAINST THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR FOR PROBLEMS
ON THE PROJECT.
THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR
UNBEKNOWNST TO ME FILES A CLAIM
DIRECTLY WITH MY PRIVATE
INSURANCE COMPANY.
MY PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANY
NOTIFIES ME OF A CLAIM.
AND I TELL THEM IT'S A NO STEP
MEANWHILE THE HIGHER DEFENSE
ATTORNEY FOR ME.
THE FIRST MEANING ON SITE IS
HELD TO GO OVER THE PROBLEMS
THAT.
GENERATED THE CLAIM.
SCHOOL DISTRICT ALSIP
ADMINISTRATOR.
ANNOUNCES THAT THE GENERAL
CONTRACTOR WAS NEVER ENROLLED IN
THE SEP AND THEREFORE IS NOT
COVERED BY THE SET.
NOW THE QUESTION IS WHY.
WE'RE THEY ALLOW DOING NEVER IN
ROLE AND HOW COULD THIS HAPPEN.
SO FAR THERE'S BEEN NO ANSWER
THAT VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION.
MY INSURANCE COMPANY FINALLY HAD
TO SEND THE LETTER DECLINATION
FOR THE COVERAGE AS IT DOES NOT
EXIST FOR THIS PROJECT.
THEY ALSO PRISON LIMBO THE OWNER
HAS DEMANDED RESTITUTION FOR THE
SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
IT SPENT ON AN OPERATING
WATERTIGHT SOLAR SYSTEM THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR HAS TO MAKE
IT RIGHT.
BUT BELIEVES IT HAS A CLAIM
AGAINST ME MY INSURANCE COMPANY
RIGHTFULLY US TONIGHT LIABILITY.
FOR ANYTHING TO DO WITH THIS
CLAIM.
THE DISTRICT DOES THAT CARRIER.
IS STANDING ON THE SIDELINE
SAYING THERE'S A DISCONNECT IN
COVERAGE.
BECAUSE THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR
WAS NEVER ENROLLED AND THE REFER
HAS A SUBCONTRACT WITH THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR NOT THE
OWNER.
IF YOU CAN KEEP UP WITH THAT.
THE DISTRICT GO SIP
ADMINISTRATOR SAYING HE DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND HOW SOMETHING LIKE
THIS COULD HAPPEN.
MEANWHILE THE POTENTIAL FROM THE
ENTIRE LIABILITY REMAINS ON MY
COMPANY ON A PROJECT FOR WHICH I
SEEM TO BE CURRENTLY UNINSURED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COULD JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE CHRIS WALKER
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SHEETMETAL OR
CONDITIONING CONTRACT
[inaudible]
I GIVE.
IF YOU'RE A MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THAT HE
BERNACCHI A MAP CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE CONFERENCE THE
PLUMBING HEATING PIPING INDUSTRY
THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION AND
UNITED CONTRACTORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARKLAND
EARLY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ROOFING CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
HERE IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL THAT BUILT
THE REPRESENTING THE SOCIO
GENERAL CONTRACTORS IN.
CHAIR MEMBERS RJ SAID ABOUT THIS
ONLY HALF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS
SPECIALTY CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
I'D SAY NUNS ANY OPPOSITION.
DON'T YOU THINK ROOM AT THE
TABLE FOR THE OPPOSITION PLEASE
[inaudible]
WELL.
AND WHETHER COMING UP.
WE COULD ESTABLISH FORCED STONE
HERE CUNNINGHAM CHAU CHIU.
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAVE WALRATH I REPRESENT THE
COALITION PRODUCT WHAT SCHOOL
HOUSING.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED AND IT IS ON
THE INDEMNIFICATION QUESTION
THAT WAS RAISED.
I DURING THE TESTIMONY OF THE
SUPPORTERS.
ESSENTIALLY.
AS A SCHOOL DISTRICT EMPLOYER.
AN OWNER OF A PROJECT.
WHEN WE GO HOW IF WE'RE GOING TO
BE ASKING FOR STATE FUNDS?
AND IT'S OVER MILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAVE TO GO TO A PRE
QUALIFICATION PROCESS.
THAT REQUALIFICATION PROCESS HAS
TO BE CONSISTENT.
WITH THE STRUCTURE DEVELOP I THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS.
AND IF IT'S OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WHICH ALMOST EVERYTHING
ELSE.
I WILL BE LOOKING AT USING
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS
WHO ARE REGISTERED AND WE MUST
USE THOSE WERE REGISTERED WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS.
AS AN OWNER WE ARE NOT BUILDERS
WE'RE NOT CONTRACTORS.
AT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
OUR JOB IS PROVIDE AN EDUCATION
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE ADEQUATELY HOUSE.
SO THE SITUATION COMES UP AND
THE WAY WE'VE READ THIS BILL.
IS THAT THE INDEMNIFICATION
PROVISIONS WOULD CHANGE.
AND BY CHANGING THOSE PROVISIONS
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT ON I WOULD
HAVE ASSUMED LIABILITY THAT THEY
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE. FOR
PROBLEMS THAT WERE CREATED ON
THE JOB SITE.
MOST LIKELY UP BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT EMPLOYEES CONTRACTORS THAT
WE HAVE HIRED.
UNDER THE PROCESS THAT
SUPPOSEDLY WILL PROVIDE US
QUALITY.
CONTRACTORS AND SUBCONTRACTORS.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECT COMES IN AND DOES NOT
HAVE [inaudible]
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM.
THE LIABILITY ISSUE WE
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN.
OUR OUR CONCERN IS THAT A UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE'RE
CURRENTLY INDEMNIFY.
THE TAXPAYER WOULD BE ON THE
HOOK. FOR TRYING TO CORRECT THE
SITUATION.
THAT WAS NOT OF THEIR MAKING.
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE UP.
I THINK THAT.
MARIN PIN AND I WITH THAT
STATEWIDE EDUCATIONAL WRAP UP
PROGRAM JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
--
WE REPRESENT --
WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT ARE OUR
MEMBERS --
IT WE FIVE FIND IT OVER HOT WE
COVER OVER FIVE THOUSAND
CONTRACTORS IN THE PAST.
AND JUST FOR A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION ABOUT UP
OPPOSITION BEING THEY SAID IT
WAS GOING TO SAY WHEN A FACEBOOK
FRIENDS ANYMORE SKIP IT
[inaudible]
WE ARE.
WE YEAH WE TRY WHAT THAT WHAT
STAFF CUT MEAN TO THEM MONTHS
AGO ASKING FOR DAYS PLOT THIS
SECTION TO COME OFF.
AND WE'VE. FIVE SIX WEEKS PRESS
ARE NEED I NEED FOR THAT OUT
CLASS TO COME UP BUT NOT INTO
RECENTLY WERE TOLD THAT THAT WAS
NOT COMING OFF SO THAT'S WHY.
THAT WE HAVE TO AYE WHY ACTUALLY
WENT FROM SUPPORT AMENDED TO
OPPOSE THEM AND THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITE.
RUNNING AROUND ACROSS THE WEEKLY
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO BOTH MUST
AMENDED.
AND OUR CONCERNS ARE PRIMARILY
WITH THE INDEMNITY PROVISIONS
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SING NONE OF BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND CENTER
PERHAPS YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT
THE CONCERN ABOUT THE INDEMNITY.
SURE WHO I'LL BE THAT'S MISTER
DOM.
ALRIGHT SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THE LETTER OF
OPPOSITION FROM THE SCHOOL
[inaudible]
CONSTITUENCIES.
INDICATED TO ME THAT THEY WANT
TO MAINTAIN AN IMMUNITY
[inaudible]
RELIABILITY AND WHEREAS THE
LETTER SAID THAT SUBCONTRACTOR
SIT ON THE SIDELINES --
WE DON'T THINK THAT THE ROOFER
SHOULD PAY FOR THE ELECTRICIAN'S
ERRORS.
SO WHAT THE BILL DOES CLARIFY
FOR ALL TYPES OF CONSTRUCTION A
CONSISTENT BIDDING PROCESS
WHEREBY WE KNOW AS
SUBCONTRACTORS Y. TYPE OF
INSURANCE IS BEING OFFERED TO US
UNDER THIS RAP PROGRAM.
IT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
PARTICULAR WOULD OFFER ADEQUATE
[inaudible]
LIABILITY PROVISIONS IN TERMS OF
DEDUCTIBILITY.
THE TERM OF THE POLICY HOW LONG
AFTERWARDS THAT THE PROJECT IS
DONE EXCEPTIONS TO THE POLICY.
THAT I THINK THEY HAVE SOMETHING
TO TALK ABOUT.
BUT THEN TO SAY THAT THIS IS A
COST TO THE TAXPAYERS WHEN IN
FACT.
IF THEY HAD OFFER THIS
INFORMATION PREVIOUSLY AND INFO
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THE KETTLE CALLING THE POT
BLACK.
IT'S IT'S A MATTER OF THEM NOT
OFFERING AN ADEQUATE INSURANCE
POLICY TO BEGIN WITH.
THAT WE HAVE TO LABOR WITHIN
COULD BE ON THE HOOK FOR YEARS
TO COME.
SO WE DON'T THINK THEIR
ARGUMENTS ARE VALID.
I THINK THEY MISINTERPRETED THE
BILL.
AND THIS IS STATE POLICY THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE'VE TRIED
TO DO LAST YEAR WITH PAYMENTS
FROM PUBLIC ENTITIES.
SO FOR THAT REGARD FOR THOSE
REASONS WE THINK THAT THEM THEIR
ARGUMENTS HAVE MISPLACED.
I I STRUGGLE A BIT WITH THAT
THAT EXPLANATION I THINK I'M
NOT.
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT THAT THIS
IS IN FACT SHIFTING THE
INDEMNITIES OF THOSE I WOULD BE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
THIS BILL AND HAVING GONE
THROUGH THIS.
BEEN HAVING BEEN ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD WHERE THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS
CAUSED BY A SUBCONTRACTOR IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
TAXPAYERS WERE THEN OUT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THEIR
INVESTMENT.
EVEN THOUGH WE WON THE SUIT WE
BASICALLY PAID PENNIES ON THE
DOLLAR [inaudible]
AND HAVING BEEN.
A PART OF A GOVERNING
ORGANIZATION NOT THE EXPERTISE
AND CONSTRUCTION.
THAT IT SOARED SHIFTING THAT
BURDEN OBLIGATIONS FOR INSURANCE
OUR OBLIGATIONS TO BE
[inaudible]
PROACTIVE SHIFTING THAT'S A
PUBLIC AGENCY IS IS REALLY THAT
RESEMBLE BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
THE EXPERTS AND THAT'S SO AYE
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT THIS
BILL.
SHIFTS THE INDEMNITY.
IN IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY IF I WAS
BY I DO BRISTLE A BIT AT YOUR
POT CALLING THE KETTLE BLACK
ISSUE BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE THAT
EXPECTING.
A PUBLIC AGENCY TO TO BE --
TO BE EXPERTS IN IN SOMETHING
THAT THAT THEY'RE REALLY NOT AND
TO BE PUTTING ONLINE VERY.
LIMITED PUBLIC DOLLARS
ESPECIALLY WHEN SOMETHING IS
FUNDED THROUGH A THROUGH BOND OR
OR OTHER PROVISIONS SO IT'S I
THINK WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT HOW WE'RE PUSHING BACK ON
ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND LOCAL
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU OTHER WHY I THINK I
THINK THE POINT WAS WITH THE
MORE INFORMATION.
THAT ACTUALLY IF WE IF.
WE ALL HAD.
IMPLENIA FORMATION WHAT ACTUALLY
WOULD SAVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND
IN THE LONG RUN.
I THINK THAT'S A POINT HE WAS
MAKING.
YEAH OKAY LA IF LITIGATION
ENSUES THAT'S THE TAXPAYER HOPE
YEAH WE DON'T BUT THE WHOLE
POINT IS.
WITH ADDITIONAL.
DISCLOSURES THAT THE CHANCES OF
THAT HAPPENING ARE GONNA BE
LASSEN THAT'S I THINK THAT'S THE
POINT OF THE BILL.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECONDS SENATOR.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I GET ALL THIS DOES IS IT
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
SO ALL PARTIES HAVE ACCESS TO IT
SO THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR THEIR
WHAT THEY'RE SIGNING UP FOR I
BELIEVE THAT WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IT
ACTUALLY WILL SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE LESS
LITIGATION AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
DON'T AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHAO CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN PLANE CHEN
AYE REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THINK
IT IS JIM AND IT'S A VERY
MEMBERS.
ITEMS NUMBER ONE AND FOUR FOR
THOSE WHO HAD HEARD EARLIER WERE
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA.
AND I'LL TAKE AS SENATOR DODD
COMES UP HERE WHO IS NEXT I'LL
TAKE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA AND LETS ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO PULL AN ITEM.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND ON CONSENT KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AND ALSO TRY.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS S.
B. FIVE A TO PORTANTINO S. B.
NINE TWENTY FIVE BELL.
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE FIGHT
ACT SP THIRTEEN TWENTY STERN AND
S. B. FIFTEEN HUNDRED FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON VETERANS AFFAIRS
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
GOOD MORNING TO NUMBER THREE SB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE STARTS WHEN IT
WOULD ANSWER.
GREAT GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
OUT S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE TO HELP
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM FUTURE
DATA BREACHES AND PUNISH
COMPANIES THAT FAIL TO PROTECT
DATA.
THE EQUIFAX BREACH AFFECTED A
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION
CONSUMERS 59% OF THE UNITED
STATES POPULATION.
MAKING IT THE LARGEST THEFT OF
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS.
IN HISTORY.
UNDER CURRENT LAW CONSUMERS IT.
IN THE FACT HAVE NO RECOURSE
AGAINST EQUIFAX OR OTHER BIG
CORPORATIONS THAT NEGLECT
PROTECTING OUR PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
WITH MORE MORE BRIDGES.
IT PERSONAL INFORMATION
AVAILABLE ON THE DARK WEB
ESTABLISHING THE DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN TO THE TO IS
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE.
IF YOUR IDENTITY GET STOLEN HOW
CAN YOU POSSIBLY KNOW WHETHER
THE DATA CAME FROM EQUIFAX
BREACH WORK COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PARTY.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE WILL
UPDATE CALIFORNIA'S DATA BREACH
LAWS GIVING CONSUMERS RECOURSE
SO THEY'LL BE AN INCENTIVE FOR
COMPANIES TO TAKE REASONABLE
SECURITY MEASURES. TO PROTECT
OUR DATA.
THIS BILL CLARA CLARIFIES THAT
THE CONSUMERS COVERED BY DATA
BREACH PROTECTIONS NOT JUST A
CUSTOMER.
THE EQUIFAX BREACH DEMONSTRATED
THE CONSUMERS CANNOT ALWAYS BE
DEFIED THAT'S CUSTOMERS.
A LOT THIS BILL ALSO ALLIANCE
THE INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT
WITH THE CONFIDENTIAL.
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT BY ADDING
DAMAGES OF BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED
AND A THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
FAILURE TO TAKE REASONABLE
SECURITY MEASURES AND FAILURE TO
NOTIFY CUSTOMERS.
THUS DISCOURAGING BRIDGES BY
ADDING TEETH OFF.
HE HAD HOLDS COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE HARM THEY
BECAUSE AS A RESULT OF DATA
BREACHES BY CLARIFYING THAT THE
CONSUMER ME EEK TO READ.
SEEK REDRESS UP TO FOUR YEARS
FROM WHEN THEY SUFFER FINANCIAL
HARM NOT WHEN THE BREACH JUST
WHEN THE BRIDGE CURSE.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES CLEAR THE
CONSUMERS CAN JOIN A CLASS
ACTIONS TO HOLD A NEGLIGENT THE
COMPANY ACCOUNTABLE.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF WHAT A
REASONABLE SECURITY MEASURES AND
HOW TO DEFINE THEM.
IN A SEPT IN THIS THAT SENATE WE
TOOK NARROWING AMENDMENTS THAT
MAKE CLEAR THE BILL ONLY APPLIES
IF THE BUSINESS.
DOES NOT.
IN CRYPTO REDACT DATA LET ME
JUST REPEAT THAT.
IN WE TOOK A AMENDMENTS THAT
MAKE CLEAR THAT.
THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES IF A
COMPANY DOES NOT ENCRYPT
REDACTED AT ALSO.
KEEP THE NAMES PLOT SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER OR FINANCIAL
ACCOUNT INFORMATION.
IT DOESN'T APPLY IF IT DOES NOT
MAINTAIN REASONABLE SECURED.
SECURITY SECURITY MEASURES
REQUIRED UNDER THE EXISTING LAW.
AND IS BREACHED.
AGAIN THIS IS THE COMMONSENSE
MEASURE TO HELP PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM FUTURE DATA
BREACHES AND PUNISH COMPANIES
THAT FAIL TO PROPERLY PROTECT.
OUR SENSITIVE PERSONAL DATA.
WITH ME TODAY --
I HAVE BUT TIMOTHY BLOOD WHO'S A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS CALIFORNIA IT EMILY
RUSH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALPERS.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU.
I AM SICK AND I'M EMILY RASH I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALPERS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP.
I WORKOUT PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND WE WORKED ON BILLS
TWENTY YEARS AGO TO ESTABLISH
THE NATION'S FIRST SECURITY
FREEZE MEASURE GIVING CONSUMERS
THE ABILITY ABILITY TO BETTER
PROTECT THEIR INFORMATION.
AS WELL AS DATA BREACH
NOTIFICATION BELLS AYE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY CONSUMERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STILL AT THE RISK
OF IDENTITY THEFT.
ACCORDING TO ONE STUDY THERE WAS
SEVENTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
AMERICANS OR 70% OF THE
POPULATION OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN THAT WERE VICTIMS OF
IDENTITY THEFT IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND THE MEAN
FRAUD AMOUNT WAS OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR IDENTITY THEFT
VICTIMS.
AND I AM WE ARE READY TO WE
ALREADY KNEW THAT.
IDENTITY THEFT AND DATA BREACHES
WERE A BIG PROBLEM BUT THEN OF
COURSE --
THE EQUIFAX DATA BREACH OCCURRED
LAST YEAR IT WAS LAST MAY WHEN
EQUIFAX FAILED TO INSTALL BASIC
SECURITY UPDATES ON THEIR
SYSTEMS.
DIDN'T DISCOVER IT THAT PROBLEM
FOR MORE THAN TWO MONTHS AND
OVER HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
AMERICANS HAD THEIR DATA BREACH
DATA BREACHED.
I'M I WAS ONE OF THEM WHAT OF
THOSE NEARLY HALF OF AMERICA WHO
POPPED UP ON THE LIST FROM
EQUIFAX.
AND I MADE SURE THAT I'D SIT SAT
DOWN.
AND HONEST IT TOOK AWHILE TO
MAKE SURE THAT I WENT THROUGH
AND I ACTUALLY ASKED FOR
SECURITY FREEZE FROM EACH OF THE
THREE MAJOR CREDIT REPORTING
AGENCIES.
SIGNED UP TO GET A PIN NUMBER SO
THAT I COULD JUMP HELP PROTECT
MYSELF FROM NEW ACCOUNT FRAUD.
ON BUT ALL HAVE TO MONITOR THIS
FOR YEARS TO COME BECAUSE AMONG
YOU KNOW THE PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT WERE BREACHED
OF MIND WHERE THINGS LIKE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER DRIVER'S LICENSE
THINGS THAT WON'T GO AWAY.
UNDER THIS BILL WE ARE REALLY
HERE AND WE DECIDE TO CO SPONSOR
THE SPELL --
AND WORK WITH SENATOR DIED
BECAUSE WE ARE REALLY TRYING TO
PREVENT THE NEXT NEGLIGENT DATA
BREACH FROM OCCURRING HERE IN
THE STATE.
I'M THE WITH THIS BILL SAYS IS
THAT WHEN A COMPANY IS NEGLIGENT
WITH CONSUMERS DATA.
AND A BREACH OCCURS THEY SHOULD
HAVE TO PAY THE CONSUMER.
ON FOR THE WORK THE TO DO THAT
WE HAVE NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
OURSELVES MUCH LESS THE FACT
THAT WE COULD BE THEM VICTIMS OF
IDENTITY THEFT.
THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES TO
BUSINESSES THAT DO NOT ENCRYPT A
REDACT CONSUMERS DATA.
THAT KEEP CONSUME AT EITHER THEN
OUR NAME PLUS EITHER SO SECURITY
NUMBER DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
FINANCIAL ACCOUNT INFORMATION SO
THAT.
THE PIECES OF INFO THAT WILL
MAKE IT MOST LIKELY THAT WE ARE
VICTIMS OF IDENTITY THEFT LATER.
IF THE BUSINESS FAILS TO PROTECT
OUR DATA AS REQUIRED BY CURRENT
LAW AND THEN THE DATA IS
PREACHED IN THOSE INSTANCES.
I AM A CONSUMER COULD SEEK
RECOURSE FROM THE COMPANY AND E
THINK THAT'S IN HIGH HARLEY
APPROPRIATE.
I'M BENEFICIAL FOR CONSUMERS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WILL ACTUALLY
INCENTIVIZE COMPANIES TO KEEP
OUR INFORMATION SECURE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
I URGE DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU.
WHOSE.
THANK YOU AGAIN MY NAME IS
TIMOTHY BLOOD I'M FROM SAN DIEGO
--
IDEA IN IN ADDITION TO BEING A
BOARD MEMBER OF CHAU SEE --
I'VE ALSO LITIGATED NUMBER OF
DATA BREACH --
BILL ARE CASES I'M.
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF DATA PRIVACY FOR
DECADES LITERALLY SINCE THE
SINCE THE EARLY SEVENTIES.
YOU RITA A BILL THAT WAS PASSED
IN THE LAWN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES IT SOUNDS LIKE IT WAS.
IT WAS UP PASSED YESTERDAY IN
HIS IS CURRENT AND ADDRESSES THE
CONCERNS THE CALIFORNIANS
CALIFORNIANS HAVE OVER DATA
PRIVACY.
PROBLEM IS TECHNOLOGY HAS
OUTSTRIPPED THE LAW SO WE DON'T
NOW HAVE A* ANY STATUTORY
PROTECTION THAT ACTUALLY WORKS
IT ENDS UP PROVIDING THE
INCENTIVES OF OF GOOD COMPANIES
TO PROTECT DATA.
IT INCENTIVIZE BAD COMPANIES TO
NOT PROTECT DATA AND HAS THE
EFFECT OF ALLOWING A DATA PROP
IDENTITY THEFT THIEVES --
OPPORTUNITIES TO OBTAIN DATA --
AYE PRIVACY DATA PRIVATE DATA
AND THEN --
USING IT USE THAT THE STEEL ARE.
CONSUMER INFORMATION AND MONEY.
I'M THIS BILL DOES A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT THINGS I'M.
FIRST OF ALL CHANGES THE
DEFINITION OF OF A CONSUMER TO
ALL INDIVIDUALS THAT IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE WAY USED
TO BE IS THE PERSON OR THE
COMPANY THAT YOU HAD A BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
A WAS THE ONE THAT HAD YOU WRITE
YOUR AT PRIVATE INFORMATION THAT
IS NO LONGER THE CASE NOW IT IS
LARGE DATA AGGREGATORS THAT HAVE
YOUR INFORMATION.
PEOPLE YOU DO NOT HAVE ANY
COMMERCIAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
EQUIFAX IS A GOOD EXAMPLE
THEY'RE NOT JUST A CREDIT
BUREAU.
BECAUSE OF THEY ARE ALSO DATA
AGGREGATOR IN FACT THEY ARE
PRIMARILY A DATA AGGREGATOR AND
REGULAR CONSUMERS HAVE NO.
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP WITH
COMPANIES LIKE EQUIFAX IN TERMS
OF OF WHAT THEY ACTUALLY DO WITH
THAT INFORMATION SO YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEM.
THAT CHANGES THAT SO THAT IT
WOULD APPLY TO WOULD MAKE THIS
STATUTE AFFABLE OUGHT TO PROTECT
ALL PEOPLE --
DOT RATHER THAN JUST PEOPLE WHO
HAVE A BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP THE
SECOND THING IT DOES IS IT
PROVIDES FOR STATUTORY DAMAGES
AND I THINK THERE'S SOME
CONFUSION.
ON WHAT THE STATUTORY DAMAGES
PROVISION DOES THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT CONCEPTS AT ISSUE
HERE.
ONE CONCEPT IS IDENTITY THEFT SO
THAT'S WHEN AID IDENTITY THIEF
TAKES YOUR PERSONAL INFORMATION.
AND ACTUALLY USE THAT TO DRAIN
YOUR BANK ACCOUNT TO STEAL YOUR
IDENTITY TO PROFIT SOMEHOW
ILLEGALLY FROM YOUR INFORMATION.
WE WANT TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING.
ONCE THERE IS A DATA BREACH
WHICH IS WHEN THE DATA THIEVES
GO IN AND TAKE THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION FROM A COMPANY THAT
IS NOT ADEQUATELY PROTECTING IT.
PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE STEPS IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AGAINST IDENTITY THEFT.
AND WHAT THE STATUTORY DAMAGES
DO IS THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
SPEND THE MONEY THAT THEY NEED
TO SPEND. TO TAKE THOSE STEPS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE EQUIFAX CHARGES
TWENTY DOLLARS A MONTH. FOR
IDENTITY THEFT PROTECTION NOW
THIS IS NOT COMPREHENSIVE
PROTECTION IT'S NOT GONNA GOING
TO PREVENT IDENTITY THEFT.
BUT IT IS GOING TO MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT OF IDENTITY THEFT FROM
OCCURRING.
IT WILL EFFECTIVELY IF PEOPLE
HAVE IDENTITY THEFT PROTECTION.
IT WILL DISINCENTIVE BUYS
IDENTITY THIEVES.
FROM FROM STEALING INFORMATION
TO BEGIN WITH.
AND THEN USING UP THE PROFIT
BECAUSE IT'LL BE HARDER FOR THEM
TO PROFIT IF PEOPLE HAVE
IDENTITY THEFT PROTECTION.
SO IT'S TWENTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND SO FOR IT AND THE STATURE
DAMAGES RANGE FROM.
A TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
VIOLATION TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER VIOLATION WHAT TWENTY
DOLLARS A MONTH THAT ONE CAN DO
THE MATH --
TUNER DOLLARS IS LESS THAN ONE
YEAR'S WORTH OF IDENTITY THEFT
PROTECTION.
MOST EXPERTS WILL TELL YOU THAT
THAT IS IN ALMOST ALL DAY THAT.
A DATA BREACH CASES ONE YEAR IS
NOT REALLY ENOUGH IDENTITY THEFT
PROTECTION BUT IT'S A GOOD
START.
A THOUSAND DOLLARS OBVIOUSLY
DOING THE MATH IS JUST OVER FOUR
YEARS OF IDENTITY THEFT
PROTECTION.
IF YOU HAVE YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
AYE NUMBER TAKEN THAT IS AN
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE PIECE OF
INFORMATION AND YOU WILL NEED TO
PROTECT YOURSELF FROM IDENTITY
THEFT FOR FAR MORE THAN FOUR
YEARS BECAUSE YOU HAVE YOUR YOUR
SOUL SECURITY NUMBER. FOR YOUR
ENTIRE LIFE SO HAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF STATUTORY DAMAGES
IT'S IT'S NOT THAT PEOPLE HAVE
NOT SUFFERED ECONOMIC HARM.
PEOPLE HAVE SUFFERED ECONOMIC
HARM.
THEY NEED TO TAKE STEPS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM IDENTITY
THEFT.
NOW KEEP IN MIND WHAT THIS ENDS
UP DOING.
THE BILL WILL INCENTIVIZE BAD
COMPANIES COMPANIES THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY TAKING THE TIME AND
EFFORT.
PROTECT PEOPLE'S INFORMATION AND
IT INCENTIVIZE THEM TO ACT LIKE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF COMPANIES
THAT ACTUALLY DO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S INFORMATION.
THE OTHER THING IT DOES IS IF
PEOPLE BY ADEQUATE IDENTITY
THEFT PROTECTION.
THEN IT STARS THE DATA THIEVES.
THEY THE THIEVES LIKE ANY FEE.
FOLLOW THE PATH LEAST RESISTANCE
IF THEY CANNOT PROFIT OFF OF
YOUR PERSONAL INFORMATION
BECAUSE YOU'VE TAKEN STEPS TO
PROTECT YOURSELF.
IDENTITY THEFT WILL DECREASE.
PETER UP PLEASE I ABSOLUTELY AND
THEN THE LAST PIECE OF IS THE
NOTIFICATION.
PORTION OF IT THE NOTIFICATION
PORTION OF THE STATUTE --
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO --
CONSEQUENCES TO A COMPANY THAT
FAILS TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE IN THE
EVENT OF A OF A DATA BREACH.
OF THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
STATURE DAMAGES TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO DO THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
JERRY MEMBERS KEVIN BACON
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THAT.
SET THE COURT ON BEHALF OF
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
MAY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE AT UTILITY
WORKERS UNION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SING KNOWN AS OUR OPPOSITION
.
ONE MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M SARAH BOOT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION.
SCOPE OF THIS BILL IS MASSIVE IT
APPLIES TO BUSINESSES OF EVERY
SIZE NON PROFITS ASSOCIATIONS
UNIONS.
BASICALLY IT'S YOUR DATA IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL'S EXPANSION OF WHO CAN
SUE MASSIVE.
ANY CONSUMER CAN BRING A CLAIM
CONSUMERS DEFINED AS ANY NATURAL
PERSON NOT EVEN LIMITED
CALIFORNIANS.
MOST TROUBLING IS THIS BILLS
MASSIVE EXPANSION OF LIABILITY
SP ELEVEN TWENTY ONE CREATES TO
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
AND THEY DON'T REQUIRE ANY PROOF
OF INJURY.
EVEN WORSE THE NEW DEFINITION OF
DATA BREACH IN THIS BILL DOESN'T
EVEN REQUIRE THAT A CONSUMER'S
DATA BE TAKEN.
ON TOP OF ALL THAT S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE WOULD IMPOSE A
MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
MAXIMUM OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN STATUTORY DAMAGES PER PERSON
PER INCIDENT AGAIN WITH NO PROOF
OF INJURY.
LIABILITY FACED BY BUSINESS OR
NON PROFIT WOULD BE STAGGERING
LEFT BUT COMPANIES OUT OF
BUSINESS. FOR EXAMPLE A SMALL
BUSINESS WITH JUST A THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS BUT SUFFERS A DATA
BREACH COULD BE FACING CIVIL
LIABILITY OF UP TO MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND NOT ONLY THAT THE STATUTORY
DAMAGES ARE CUMULATIVE MEETING
THE STOCK ON TO OTHER DAMAGES SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE IS ADOPTED.
AND NOT PRIVACY INITIATIVE IS
PASS WHICH ALSO CONTEMPLATES A
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STATUTORY
DAMAGES PER PERSON PER BREACH.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THAT SAME SMALL
BUSINESS WITH A THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS.
IS LOOKING AT BUT DAMAGES OF UP
TO TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FACE OF SUCH MASSIVE RISK
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS ARE
GONNA BE LEVERAGED INTO AN
IMMEDIATE SETTLEMENT REGARDLESS
OF THE STRENGTH OF THEIR DEFENSE
SO THE ARGUMENT TO THIS BILL IS
ONLY GONNA APPLY.
TO BAD ACTORS ARE SIMPLY NOT
TRUE IT WILL UNQUESTIONABLY
RESULT IN SHE COUNTY TO PREACH
LAWSUITS.
AND ALL THESE LAWSUITS ARE NOT
GONNA MAKE CALIFORNIANS ANY SAY
FURTHER NOT GONNA PREVENT DATA
BREACHES BUSINESSES ALREADY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT INCENTIVES TO AVOID
DATA BREACHES IN THESE INCLUDE
CIVIL LAWSUITS BY CUSTOMERS AND
CREDIT CARD COMPANIES.
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS BY AG'S
DAMAGES TO THE REPUTATION
DAMAGES TO THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEIR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
CURRENT LAW RIGHT NOW --
COMPANIES RD.
IN MANY CASES BUT REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE --
MITIGATION SERVICES LIKE PRE
CRIME.
IN THE WAKE OF A BRIDGE AGAIN
THAT'S ABOUT TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
A POP RIGHT THERE AS WE HEARD.
ONE THE OTHER THING THIS BILL IS
NOT GONNA HELP THOSE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY INJURED DUE TO A DATA
BREACH OF S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
ONCE ADOPTED A CONSUMER CLAIMS
ARE MOST LIKELY CAN BE ROLLED
INTO EARLY CLASS ACTION
SETTLEMENTS.
SO IF THE CONSUMER DOES SUFFER
AN INJURY AT A LATER DATE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE WITHOUT
RECOURSE.
NO ONE FINAL POINT I WANT TO
MAKE -- THIS
BILL DOES NOT CREATE A SAFE
HARBOR FOR COMPANIES ENCRYPT
DATA --
ENCRYPTION IS DEFINITELY
STRONGER PROTECTION BUT IT'S NOT
IRON CLAD YOU CAN HAVE --
BROUGH A BREACH THAT RESULTS IN
THE DECRYPTION OF DATA DO TO
ASSIST TICKET CRIMINAL --
COULD BE AN ERROR BY AN EMPLOYEE
--
OFTEN DATA IS IN TRANSIT AND
IT'S NOT CRYPTIC AT THAT TIME --
AND SO COMPANY THAT GOES OUT
TROUBLE TO TAKE THE HEIGHTENED
MEASUREMENT TIGHTEN MEASURE OF
ENCRYPTION AND THEN ULTIMATELY
FACES A BREACH THEY'RE GOING TO
BE UNDER THE SAME.
STATUTORY PENALTIES ANYBODY ELSE
--
GET IT THIS AT THE OTHER DAY
THIS LAWSUIT.
EVEN THE END OF THE DAY THE
LAWSUITS CREATED BY THIS BILL.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA STOP
CYBERCRIME.
NOT GONNA PREVENT DATA BREACHES
IN THERE NOT THAT HELP MAKE
VICTIMS HOLE SO WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ASSIST WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
DORY ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
DISASSOCIATION.
ON I THINK THAT IT IS CLEAR THAT
SENATOR DODD AS HE IS --
A GOOD AT HAS IDENTIFIED A
TIMELY SOCIETAL ISSUE.
THAT IS IMPORTANT EVERYONE ON A
DATA BREACH IS A REGULAR NEWS
THEY'RE HAPPENING OFTEN THE
PUBLIC AWARE OF IT.
ON AND THEY'RE LEGITIMATELY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT TO DO --
THERE IS A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
REPORT DONE BY OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE TIME --
NOW SENATOR A COUPLE HARRIS
FIFTY MILLION RECORDS OR BREACH
OF A FOUR YEAR PERIOD. TWENTY
FOUR MILLION OF THOSE WERE
PREACHING TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH
MEANS IN THAT YEAR THREE FIFTHS
OF CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCED SOME
FORM OF DATA BREACH AS
IDENTIFIED UNDER THIS BILL.
ON THERE IS A PLETHORA OF
EVIDENCE THAT SHOWS THAT THIS
TREND IS GOING TO CONTINUE WE'RE
NOT WE DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW TO
SOLVE IT.
ON AND WHAT WE'RE LEARNING IS
THAT NOW THE CRIMINALS ARE
INCREASINGLY GOING AFTER SMALL
BUSINESSES 43% OF THE TIME.
IN CERTAIN TYPES OF ATTACKS ARE
SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED SMALL
BUSINESS --
THE US NATIONAL CYBERSECURITY
LANCE FOUND THAT 6% OF SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE UNABLE.
STAYING THERE BUSINESS SIX
MONTHS AFTER A CYBERCRIME
ATTACK.
SO IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT THIS
IS AN ISSUE.
THE QUESTION REALLY BECOMES IS
SUING.
ARM A THE WAY TO SOLVE THE ISSUE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IF IF YOU'RE A
HAMMER EVERYTHING DOES START TO
LOOK LIKE A NAIL EVENTUALLY
WHICH IS WHAT WE WANT TO SUE
ABOUT THIS.
AND I THINK THAT --
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE
COURSE OF LITIGATION IS THAT?
COM CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS WHILE
THEY DON'T ALWAYS CIVIC WE
BENEFIT THAT MUCH OF CONSUMERS
ARE A PROBLEM BECAUSE WE'VE ALL
RECEIVED THOSE.
ON NOTICES IN THE MAIL THAT
YOU'RE GONNA GET THAT YOU KNOW
EX COUPON OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
OUT OF A OUT OF A A A CLASS
ACTION.
THE ARGUMENT REALLY COMES DOWN
TO DOES IT THE TO HER.
AND WHY I'M HERE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION IS BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S CLEAR THERE'S ALREADY.
FROM LARGE AMOUNT OF DETERRENCE
ON THERE IS A TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SURVEY THAT SHOWS THAT
THAT ACTUALLY ANY DAY TO BE
BREACH ALREADY COST THE VICTIM.
WHICH IS OR TALK ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
ATTACKED CREE ON A AN AVERAGE OF
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ON IN THERE EQUIFAX
LAWSUIT WHICH IS ON THE A YOU
KNOW SORT OF THE STATED.
THAT ONE OF THE MAIN STATED --
MOTIVATORS OF THE BILL THEIR
TWENTY THREE CLASS ACTION
LAWSUITS AGAINST A EQUIFAX I'M
THEY DROPPED. TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN MARKET SHARE THE DAY
AFTER IT WAS ANNOUNCED THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT COMPANIES ALREADY
HAVE TO TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY --
AND SO WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT THIS IS A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT.
AS ARE UP MY COLLEAGUES ARE
TESTIFIED IT DOES NOT
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN HOW
SERIOUS THE DATA THAT'S PREACHED
IS AND WHAT THE PENALTY SHOULD
BE.
ON IT ACCUMULATES --
IT'S A BLUNT INSTRUMENT BECAUSE
IT HITS EVERYBODY IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THE BOMB THERE BEEN
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN NOTICED.
DATA BREACHES IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE I TESTIFIED THIS ON THIS
IN THE SENATE THAT INCLUDES THE
BAY AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT.
I'M WHICH IS NOT COVERED BY THE
BILL BECAUSE IT EXCLUDES --
PUBLIC ENTITIES --
AND SO ON IT'S A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT BECAUSE I'M IT DOES
NOT ALLOW ON EH HELP PEOPLE
ACTUALLY PREVENT.
DATA BREACHES IT JUST PUNISHES
AND THE FINAL THING I'LL SAY IS.
ON I GET THAT THERE'S A STANDARD
OF REASONABLENESS HERE BUT
BECAUSE YOU'RE A MAN IN A
STATUTE THAT REQUIRES.
PUBLIC NOTICE OF DATA BREACHES
WHICH WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE ON AND IF YOU
LOOK THROUGH THAT THAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S --
LIST A LOT OF PEOPLE BE COVERED
UNDER THIS BILL THEIR OFFICES
HAVE BEEN BROKEN INTO AND THEIR
PHYSICAL.
COMPUTERS OF INSTALLING ON AND
SO YOU KNOW DOES OF THE TYPE OF
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE AND THE
DEFENSE SAYING WE TOOK EVERY
REASONABLE PRECAUTION WE COULD
BUT THERE WAS A DATA BREACH.
THEY WILL GET SUED THEY WILL
HAVE TO SETTLE BECAUSE OF THE
ASTRONOMICAL NUMBERS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE BILL AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
SO WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU KNOW THE THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
TO GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MARGARET GLAD TO HEAR ABOUT ALL
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE BANKING NETWORK AND
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AS CHRIS MAKAYLA
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KEVIN
GOULD WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS IN
OPPOSITION. TO TURN MEMBERS
COUNTY DELGADO WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KEVIN KILLING.
THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
TO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DERRICK
THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIR DEVON ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF THE RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION AND FAMILY WINE
MAKERS A CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
JOANNE BETTENCOURT.
REPRESENTING THE SECURITIES
SORRY.
WITH SECURITIES INDUSTRY AND
FINANCIAL MARKETS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ROSSBACH THE WITH
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TERRY
THOMAS ON THE HAVE THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
AND OPPOSITION.
AND A JURY DOES BUT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED INVESTIGATORS AND UP.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WRITE A LETTER [inaudible]
CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I ID ONE
QUESTION THAN ONE COMMENT SO I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
BALLOT MEASURE IN THIS TOPIC
THAT'S GOING TO NOVEMBER I HAD
THOUGHT ABOUT THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN THAT MEASURE AND YOUR
BILL COULD YOU GO INTO THAT JUST
SO WE HAVE A SENSE.
IF IT HAPPENS TO PASS.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I I HAVE
NOT.
I DON'T KNOW MAYBE MY WITNESSES
COULD --
OPINED ON THAT I HAVEN'T SPENT
MUCH TIME.
NOT YET IT THERE IS OVERLAP AND
AS I UNDERSTAND IT IN COME
AUGUST OR LATER.
IN THE YEAR THERE IS --
CHATTERING OUT AMENDMENTS THAT
CAN BE DONE WITH THIS BILL SOME
I THINK IT WOULD BE IT EASY.
LANGUAGE FIX TO THIS BILL THAT
IN THE EVENT THAT THAT --
THAT BALLOT MEASURE PASSED AND
THEN THIS WOULD BE AFFECTED AND
THAT COULD BE CURIOUSLY BUT
THERE IS OVERLAP --
YOU KNOW MY PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
pVERY MUCH APPRECATE THE AUTHOR
AND YOUR SUPPORTERS I THINK FOR
ADDRESSING SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
KNOW NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED RIGHT
WE WE WE KNOW ABOUT THIS DATA
BREACHES.
OF THEIR CATASTROPHIC --
AND I I I I I WAS THE BEEN
LISTENING TO THE MARKET ALONE --
IS ENOUGH CLEARLY IT HAS NOT
PROVEN TO BE ENOUGH I THINK WE
NEED MORE WE NEED MORE FOR
CONSUMERS TO BE ABLE --
TO TO PROTECT THEIR RIGHTS THAT
BEING SAID I'M STILL THINKING
ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS PRECISELY
THE RIGHT BALANCE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THIS BILL IS
GOING TO GO TO PRIVACY IN THAT
IT HAS TO GO TO THE FLOOR.
AND I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE CONVERSATION
TO CONTINUE THAT BEEN SAID
LOOKING FORWARD TO AMENDMENTS
AND I KNOW BEING DISCUSSED.
FOR THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND FOR
THE FLOOR FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS THIS IS HARD.
ARE REALLY APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS AND AND
HOPEFULLY --
I DON'T THINK THE RIGHT ANSWER
IS DOING NOTHING UP WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING THE QUESTION IS
EXACTLY HOW IT STRUCK THAT SO.
OUT WITH THAT A I WILL BE
SUPPORTING MOVING THIS BILL OUT
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU CENTER.
FOR BRING THIS BOARD IS DEATHLY
A TOUGH ISSUE TO TAKE ON AND AND
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN.
FROM MANY IN THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND AND I APPRECIATE
HAVE NOT CHANGED ME WITH SOME OF
THEM.
ABOUT THIS BILL AS WELL ABOUT IT
AND SO THOSE.
THOSE A MENTION THAT.
IT ONLY APPLIES TO COMPANIES WHO
DO NOT ENCRYPT REDACT DATA.
AND SO A LOT OF MENTION AS
OFTENTIMES A CASE OF FOCUS ALSO
SMALL BUSINESS YEAR SMALL DISNEY
HURT.
BUT THAT I THINK ABOUT A LEASE
RETAIL.
BUSINESSES --
EVEN DOWN THE HALL TO THE COFFEE
SHOP HERE THEY HAD THE YOU SWIPE
YOUR CARD OR SOMETIMES THEY HAD
TO SQUARE.
IS THAT ENCRYPTED.
YES IT'S ENCRYPTED AND AND THERE
ARE FEDERAL LAWS THAT GOVERN
CREDIT CARD INFORMATION AND AND
VIRTUALLY ALL BUSINESSES FOLLOW
THEM.
TYPICALLY THE THE ONES THAT
DON'T FOLLOW THEM ARE THE VERY
VERY LARGE COMPANIES TARGET AND
HOME DEPOT HAD A PROBLEM WITH
THAT BECAUSE THEY WERE.
SHOCKINGLY NOT FOLLOWING --
FEDERAL LAW WITH REGARD --
TO PROCESSING CREDIT CARDS SMALL
BUSINESSES OUTSOURCE ALL OF THAT
THAT'S THAT ENDS UP BEING TAKEN
CARE OF ANYWAY.
AND THE AS IT SHOULD BE.
AND SO I AND I MENTION THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE MOST
COMMON.
YOU KNOW HAVE FOR AT LEAST BE
TELL PURPOSES OFF THE SHELF
PRODUCTS ARE ENCRYPTED WITH YOU
GET IT TO OTHERS NAPA PRODUCT
ANOTHER KIND A PRODUCT THAT'S
BECAUSE MOST COMMONLY USED --
BEFORE RETAIL PURPOSES NOW
DOESN'T MEAN THERE ARE OTHER.
AREAS IN WHICH DATA IS COLLECTED
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
RELEVANT AS WELL AND SO THERE
WOULD BE A BURDEN.
AYE ON ALL BUSINESSES INCLUDING
SMALL BUSINESSES TO HAVE --
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE DOING
WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO TO PROTECT
THE DATA I THINK ULTIMATELY
COMES DOWN [inaudible]
TO YOU KNOW.
IF AS WAS ALLUDED TO BY MY
COLLEAGUE NO --
KIND OF WHO SHOULD THE OWNERS
BEYOND AND WHO'S IN THE BEST
POSITION.
PROTECT THE DATA IS THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMER OR IS THAT
THE COMPANY BIGGER SMALL --
I ALSO AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT
THAT I I YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH
WHAT IS TRYING TO BE DONE I DO
UNDERSTAND THERE'S GONNA BE MORE
WORK DONE ON THE BILL.
OPTICALLY AS GOES IN FLORIDA AT
LEAST ONE OR TWO OTHER
COMMITTEES BEFORE GOES THE FOR
I'M I'M.
THE SENATE BUT SATISFY
SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT I'M
REALLY INTERESTED IN SEEING WHAT
THE AMENDMENTS ARE POSITIVE.
INTO A DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
CONCERNS I THINK ARE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS FROM THE OF THE VARIOUS
BUSINESS INTERESTS BUT I THINK
THE UNDERLYING.
GOAL HERE IS A OF IS NOT ONE THE
MARKET BY ITSELF WILL CORRECT --
FOR I AND I DO THINK.
GEISHAS BETTER PLACED UPON THOSE
THAT CAN ACTUALLY.
BARRETT NOW THAT BEING SAID I
THINK THAT THERE ARE THERE ARE
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION THAT AGAIN I'LL LOOK
FORWARD.
TO AMENDMENTS AND AND YOU KNOW
THE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS LAWS THAT THAT THE
NEXT COMMITTEES GOES FORWARD SO
ALL I'M ARGUING IS SUPPORTED
TODAY BUT I'M OF THE AYE AGAIN
AS I AM.
THOSE NUMBERS TO INDICATE WILL
BE INCIDENTS SEEING WHAT
AMENDMENT SELDOM OCCUR BUT
BEFORE BECAUSE OF FLOOR.
THANK YOU ISRAEL'S.
THANK YOU SENATOR I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES THAT WITHOUT A
DOUBT IT WOULDN'T THERE ARE
BREACHES.
WE DO HAVE VICTIMS I DISAGREE
THAT THE VICTIM.
IS NOT THE BUSINESS IT IS A
CONSUMER.
AND THAT'S WHO AT EIGHT IN MY
OPINION WHO WE DO NEED TO
PROTECT [inaudible]
BUT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
COULD BE PERCEIVED AS AN OVER
REACH IT'S AN ISSUE THAT NEEDS
TO BE RESOLVED.
WE DO NEED TO PROTECT THOSE
CONSUMERS --
BUT PERHAPS THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE I'M GLAD I SIT IN PRIVACY
SO I DO GET TO SEE YOUR YOUR
NEXT AMENDMENTS.
AND I I AGREE THERE WERE SOME
VERY GOOD POINTS BROUGHT UP BY
THE OPPOSITION THAT I THINK WE
REALLY NEED TO TAKE AGAIN I'M
SURE THAT YOU HAVE.
TAKE A LONG LOOK AT THOSE --
TO BE SURE THAT WHAT WE DO DOES
NOT CAUSE ADDITIONAL HARM I KNOW
THAT JUST RECENTLY HERE IN
JUDICIARY.
WE DID VOTE ON A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TODAY AT CHURCH AT CHAO'S THE
BILL.
PROVIDING THIRTY DAYS TO REPAIR
SO IF THERE IS A BREACH THEN YOU
HAVE THIRTY DAYS TO TAKE CARE OF
IT OTHERWISE THEN THERE THERE IS
A LIABILITY.
SO THESE ARE THE SORTS OF THINGS
I'D LIKE TO SEE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD INTO PRIVACY BUT I DO
THANK YOU.
FOR TAKING CARE TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE WHO.
HOW OF THIS INFORMATION?
AND THEY ALLOW A. B. DATA
BREACH.
THEY DO NEED TO BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE WITHOUT A DOUBT.
BECAUSE THOSE CONSUMERS SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF OF
HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE'S ERROR --
THE EXAMPLE GIVEN OF A COMPUTER
BEING STOLEN OBVIOUSLY THAT
WE'VE GOT TO ACCOUNT FOR SOME OF
THAT ALSO IN THE BILL.
BUT I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND I TO OUT TODAY WILL
BE SUPPORTING THAT AND DO LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT COMES --
IN PRIVACY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO THERE'S ACTUALLY A LOT
PROBABLY TO BE SET ON THIS BILL
IN THIS AREA IT'S A VERY COMPLEX
AREA AND IN FACT FOR THE SIX
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE ISSUES LIKE THIS
COME UP AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND THEY'RE ALWAYS
ATTEMPTS THAT.
INDUSTRY SCREAMS THAT THAT
CONSUMER EIGHT OR ORGANIZATIONS
TRY TO PROTECT CONSUMERS PUT ON
THE TABLE AND WHAT'S REALLY BEEN
MISSING IS THE INDUSTRY
CONVERSATION IN THIS.
THEY'RE OPPOSED ANYTHING THAT
THAT GETS ATTEMPT AT AND I THINK
YOU'RE VULNERABLE TO ALL OF
THESE ATTEMPTS TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING INCLUDING A STATEWIDE
BALLOT MEASURE.
BECAUSE THERE HASN'T REALLY BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN LOOK THAT.
AS AS A WAY TO SOLVE ALL OF
THESE ISSUES AND THERE'S A
VARIETY OF THINGS INTERNET AND
CENTER APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE
NEVER THIS TO THOSE WHO ARE NOT
[inaudible]
ENCRYPTING.
OR REDACTING INFORMATION BECAUSE
THAT IS ONE OF THE CORE ISSUES
MOSTLY TRANSACTIONS NOW THAT
HAPPENED AND AND ARE ENCRYPTED
OR SHOULD BE AND IF THEY'RE NOT.
WE'VE WE'VE LEARNED THAT THROUGH
THE TARGET BREACH IN THROUGH
THROUGH OTHER BRIDGES THAT'S
ACTUALLY FAIRLY SIMPLE TO DO
EVEN AT THAT AT THE CONSUMER
READ AND SO THE FACT THAT.
UNENCRYPTED DATA IS MOVING.
TRANSITIONING BETWEEN FROM ONE
SYSTEM TO THE NACS WHATEVER
THOSE SYSTEMS HAPPEN TO BE IS
SOMETHING THAT.
THAT THOSE WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
SHOULD BE HELD LIABLE FOR NOW I
REALLY TO WORRY ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF SOME THESE THINGS ON THE
SMALL BUSINESSES.
SMALL BUSINESSES TYPICALLY THE
LARGER THE BUSINESS THE MORE
LIKELY THAT THEY HAVE CONTROL
OVER THEIR ENTIRE PROCESS AND
AND THEY'RE GONNA OWN THE
SERVERS OR IF NOT THE COULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT TROLL OVER THE
SERVERS AND WHAT HAPPENS THERE.
A SMALLER BUSINESS IS JUST
HOSTING THEIR WEBSITE WHERE
THEIR DATABASE ESSENTIALLY ON
SOMEBODY ELSE'S SERVER THAT
SERVER COULD BE POTENTIALLY
VULNERABLE IF THERE'S A NOTHER.
DATABASE OR WEBSITE HOSTED ON
THAT SERVER THAT IS NOT BEING
KEPT UP TO DATE THAT IT DOESN'T
HAVE APPROPRIATE CORRUPTION.
BECAUSE THAT PROVIDES OFTENTIMES
AT ENTRY INTO THAT ENTIRE
SERVER.
SO IF SOMEONE HASN'T MAINTAINED
THEIR SOFTWARE HASN'T RUN
PATCHES HASN'T KEPT UP WITH IT
THEY ACTUALLY PROVIDE.
POTENTIAL VULNERABILITIES TO
ANYBODY WHO'S RESIDENT ON THAT
SERVER NOW WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT.
AS WE HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
THE EYES P. SAFE NOT US DUH
THOSE WHO PROVIDE THE SOFTWARE
STATE NOT US THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ONCE A NOT AS AND IT.
IT'S ALWAYS NOT US WELL THEN WHO
AND EVEN THOUGH IT'S DIFFICULT
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THIS BREACH
HAS CAUSED THESE DAMAGES TO A
PARTICULAR CONSUMER JUST THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE THAT THOSE
STRESS THE PANIC.
HAVING TO GO THROUGH.
A CREDIT CHECK HAVING TO GO
THROUGH A PROTECT.
THEIR INFORMATION EVEN IF THEIR
IDENTITY HAD HAS NOT YET BEEN
STOLEN.
THAT IS SOME BUT THAT IS
POTENTIALLY DAMAGES THAT THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT RISE TO THE TO
THE LEVEL THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
AND WENT ONE PARTICULAR
DATABASES BREACHED THAT'S A
SUBSET OF INFORMATION.
THERE MIGHT BE ANOTHER DATABASE
THAT GETS BREACH THAT THAT ADDS
TO THE ABILITY ESPECIALLY WITH
DATA AGGREGATORS TO THEN GO IN
AND COLLECT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ENOUGH TO PUT PIECES
TOGETHER TO THEN BE ABLE TO GO.
AND AND GET A CREDIT CARD IN
SOMEBODY'S NAME THE TAX SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER BECAUSE WITH
THAT COMBINATION OF DATA FROM
TWO DIFFERENT SOURCES NOW THEY
HAVE ENOUGH.
SO WHO'S THAT RESPONSIBLE WAS
THE FIRST BREACH WAS AT THE
SECOND GRADE THIS BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT SO UNTIL WE REALLY
HAVEN'T.
HAD A A BROADER SOLUTION TO THIS
THAN.
WE'RE GONNA BE LEFT WITH TRYING
TO SORT OUT THE BEST WE CAN DO
WHICH IS EXACTLY THIS WHICH ARE
BILLS LIKE THIS AND TRY TO SET
STANDARDS THAT IF YOU'RE NOT.
DOING SOME BASIC PROTECTIONS OF
THE DATA THAT YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR FOR YOUR CUSTOMERS THEN YES
YOU MIGHT BE ON THE HOOK FOR
STATUTORY DAMAGES FOR IT.
AND AND IF THAT DOESN'T CHANGE
BEHAVIOR A I'M NOT SURE WHAT
ELSE WELL.
ON THAT JUST BRIEFLY ON THE
CHAPTER AND OUT THE THAT DOESN'T
CHAPTER GOD AMENDMENTS GET DONE
WHEN THERE'S A CONFLICT BETWEEN
BILLS SO IF YOU WOULD DO YOU
WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THIS
BILL WOULD INTERACT WITH THE
BALLOT MEASURE SHOULD IT PASSED.
THAT HAVE TO BE TAKEN IN
COMMITTEE OR ON THE FLOOR THOSE
ARE NOT AMENDMENTS THERE CAN BE
DEALT WITH IN CHAPTER GAPS I
DON'T BELIEVE THE HOUSES LOOKS A
POTENTIAL BALLOT MEASURES THAN
AND CONFLICTS THERE.
IN ORDER TO DRIVE CHAPTER AND
OUTSIDE JUST AS A IT'S WELL
WORTH LOOKING AT IS THE
INTERPLAY BETWEEN THOSE.
TWO AND WHETHER THERE'S COMPLETE
COVERAGE OR NOT I SO FOR ME THIS
BILL SATISFIED THIS COMMITTEE I
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON TO OTHERS.
COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDS THE WORRY
IN THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY OPPOSITION AND FOR
OTHERS BUT IF NOT THIS THAN
WHAT.
YOU KNOW IF IF NOT NOW HOW HOW
ELSE DO WE PROCESS IS HOW DO WE
HAD TO PROVIDE.
SOME SECURITY FOR CUSTOMERS THAT
THE WEBSITE AS EVERYBODY IS
GOING TO DO WITHOUT EVEN
THINKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE MIGHT BE A DATA BREACH OR
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING.
SOME OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION OUT TO BE
VULNERABLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO IT DO YOU DO
GOOD AND INTERACT IN THIS WEB OF
OF COMMERCE THAT WE HAVE OUT
THERE.
AND YET THEY'RE THEN GOING TO
SUFFER AT SOME.
DAMAGE OR CONCERN OR IMPACT IN
THEIR LIVES SHOULD THERE BE A
BREACH AND I THINK IT IS
INCUMBENT ON US. TO LOOK FOR
BETTER SOLUTIONS ENSURE THAT
WE'VE GOT SOMETHING IN PLACE
THAT THAT DRIVES THE BEST
DECISIONS AND BEST PRACTICES.
FROM THE COMMUNITY ACROSS
SUPPORT AND IF A SMALL
BUSINESSES WORRIED ABOUT THIS
THEY CAN CONTRACT WITH THEIR
EYES P. THEY CAN CONTRACT WITH
THEIR WEB PROVIDER. TO ENSURE
THAT THAT THEY HAVE THE
PROTECTIONS NECESSARY AND WE
WANT TO DRIVE THEM TO THOSE
DECISIONS TO PREVENT BREACHES
BEFORE THEY EVER REALLY HAPPEN
[inaudible]
SO SENATOR.
YOU MAY CLUBS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION THIS MORNING
YOU KNOW I WAS AT A SMALL
BUSINESS BAD FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND I THOUGHT VERY HARD
ABOUT -- THE
PROVISIONS THAT YOU KNOW IN IN
THIS BILL YELL FRANKLY --
I IT AS I WENT THROUGH I THINK
WE HAD ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
YELL CUSTOMER NAMES AT OUR
COMPUTER SYSTEMS.
BUT WHAT ONE OF THE ONE OF
THINGS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS
FIRST OF ALL WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT'S FAIR FOR EVERYBODY.
AND ONLY THOSE PEOPLE.
THAT --
DON'T REASONABLY TAKE CARE OF
THEIR CUSTOMERS --
INFORMATION WE'RE NOT.
WHAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE THAT --
HAVE BEEN HACKED BY RUSSIAN
HACKERS THAT IT IS WAY BETTER
THAN THEM THEY DO ALL THAT USE
ALL THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S THAT
THAT'S FEASIBLE AT THE TIME BUT
THEY JUST GOT BEAT BY SOMEBODY
THAT'S BETTER THAN THEM.
THAT THAT THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT THIS
IS NOT ABOUT SEVENTY THAT STEALS
A COMPUTER.
YELL OUT OF SOMEBODY'S OFFICE IN
GAINS AN ADVANTAGE THAT WAY THIS
IS ABOUT PEOPLE THAT ARE TAKING
A DOING ANYTHING REASONABLE AND
LET'S TALK ABOUT EQUIFAX TAKING
A HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION.
I'D IT CAUSING IT TO BE STOLEN
AND THEN THERE DIRECTORS.
HIDING IT SELLING OFF THEIR
SHARES AND I THINK MAYBE SOME OF
THOSE LAWSUITS ARE NOT ABOUT --
THE HACKING BUT THEY'RE ABOUT --
DIRECTORS NOT DOING THEIR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY TO
OTHER SPECIFIC SHAREHOLDERS --
THEY'RE GOING TO BE --
RIGHT AT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
--
WHEN I HAD THIS IN THE THE
SENATE DID A NUMBER OF SENATORS
ARE STILL CONCERNED ABOUT?
THE HOPE WOULD YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY I CAN GET THROUGH THE
SIDE WHEN I COME BACK THEY'RE
GONNA WANT TO SEE SAFE HARBORS.
THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO SEE --
YOU KNOW SOME THINGS THAT THE
THAT MAKETHIS BILL MORE FAIR --
OR UNDERSTANDABLE NOT BE OUT OF
CONTROL ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS AS
YOU WERE CONCERNED ABOUT SO I
WOULD LIKE --
TO YA INVITE THE INDUSTRY --
THAT IS OPPOSING THIS BILL IF
THEY'VE GOT SOME IDEAS ON HOW WE
CAN MAKE THIS BILL BETTER FOR
CONSUMERS.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
--
KAMANI AND AND LET'S SIT DOWN TO
TALK ABOUT IT THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE RIBA.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF SILICON FOR
MOTION MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
PRIVACY CONSUMER PROTECTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAO [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
NO REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
YOU HAVE THREE VOTES CURRENTLY
SO WE'LL PUT THIS BILL CAUCUS
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU.
AND AS WE WAIT FOR SENATOR LARA
WE HEARD EARLIER.
ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR PAN.
THE LOOKING FOR MOTION MOTION IS
DUE PASSED ARTS ENTERTAINMENT'S.
OF THE MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
KALRA PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAO [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THAT BILL DOES HAVE THREE VOTES
IT'S THREE TWO SO WE'LL PUT IT
ON CALL.
SO WAITING FOR SENATOR LARA AND
FOR OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
COME AND AND VOTE
.
BUT SOME OF THAT LIFT THE CALL
ON SP FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PAN.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHAO CHIU HOLDEN.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
THAT BILLS CURRENTLY FOR TO SOME
GOING TO REPLACE THE CALL THANK
YOU
.
SENATOR WELCOME IN THE NEW YEAR
CHAIRING A COMMITTEE AS WELL AND
I WILL SEE YOU THERE IN A FEW
BUT I THOUGHT THAT THE PLEASE
THIS IS OUR ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR THANK YOU --
MEMBERS -- I
JUST WANNA THANK AND TAKE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OPTIMUM
STATE.
S. B. ELEVEN ANY FOR ENSURES
THAT A GAS AND PASSENGER RECORDS
OF CALIFORNIA PATRONS OF LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS AND PRIVATE BUS
COMPANIES ARE NOT DISCLOSED TO
THIRD PARTIES.
OTHER THAN ABOUT CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICER WITHOUT A COURT
ISSUED SUBPOENA WARRANT OR ORDER
THE BILL ALIGNS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S LONGSTANDING
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AND RESPONSE
TO THE RECENT INCIDENTS.
IN NEARBY STATES A HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR THESE TARGETED
ADDITIONAL PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS TO
OBTAIN A WARRANT.
OUR COURT ISSUED SUBPOENA A
COURT ORDER TO ATTAIN THESE
RECORDS THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
HERE TODAY INSURE THAT THE
BUSINESSES WILL.
STILL BE PERMITTED TO SHARE
CUSTOMER INFORMATION WITH THIRD
PARTY SERVICES PROVIDERS IN
ORDER PERFORMANCE ASIDE BUSINESS
RELATED SERVICES AND FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS.
AMENDMENTS ALSO REMOVE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT
WOULD HAVE PROHIBITED MOVIE
THEATERS AND OTHER ENTERTAINMENT
VENUES FROM SHAME PERSON
INFORMATION OF ATTENDEES AND
TICKET HOLDERS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
MY ANGER LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE PLEASED TO A CO SPONSOR OF
THE SPELL.
THE PROTECTIONS AFFORDED BY THIS
BILL ARE NEED TO BE CALIFORNIANS
FREQUENTLY HAVE TO TURN OVER A
VERY PERSONAL AND SENSITIVE
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO
PATRONIZE BUSINESSES BE IT.
GIVEN AND THEN I DETERMINE
REGISTER HOTEL TURN BUS TICKET
SIMILAR PROTECTIONS HAVE BEEN
FARTED IN OTHER AREAS SUCH AS
WITH THE READER PRIVACY ACT
WHICH CREATED PROTECTIONS ON
AROUND PEOPLE'S READING LESS.
AS DISCUSSED BY SENATOR LARA
RECENT INCIDENTS HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR THIS INVESTIGATIONS
HAVE SHOWN AND WASHINGTON
ARIZONA THAT LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS MORE FREQUENTLY
TURNING OVER LARGE SWATHS OF
CUSTOMER RECORDS. TO FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION OFFICERS IN
WASHINGTON STATE IT APPEARS THAT
THEY TURNED OVER OVER TEN
THOUSAND GUESTS NAMES.
INCLUDING THEIR NAMES BIRTH
DATES DRIVER'S LICENSE LICENSE
PLATE NUMBERS AND ROOM NUMBERS
AND MOTEL SIXES IN ARIZONA THEY
WERE GENERALLY A LIST OF ALL
GUESTS IN THE HOTEL EVERY
MORNING AND SEND IT DIRECTLY
OVER TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HAS RESULTED IN PEOPLE BEING
PICKED UP DIRECTLY FROM THEIR
HOTEL ROOM A COUPLE IS PLACED IN
DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS.
THE MAN WAS RELEASED ON BOND BUT
THE WOMAN WAS DEPORTED THE NEXT
DAY.
AND HIS ACTIONS WERE TAKEN
DESPITE UNTIL SIX HAVING A
CORPORATE POLICY SAYING THAT IT
PROTECTS THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
THAT IT GATHERS FROM ITS GAS AND
PRIVATE BUS COMPANIES HAVE ALSO
DRAWN CRITICISM --
FOR ENGAGING WITH FEDERAL AYE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT AND ONE
INCIDENTS CBP BOARDED A BUS FOR
SOMEONE BECAUSE THEY SAID ISSUES
LOOK SUSPICIOUS LIKE AN
INDIVIDUAL.
WHO HAD JUST CROSSED THE BORDER
WE THINK THIS BILL PROVIDES
COMMONSENSE PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PATRONS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU THANK YOU EXPLICITLY.
CHRISTOPHER'S UNDER THE CHAIR OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THIS IS
REALLY A CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE FOR IMMIGRANTS ARE.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY DO KNOW THAT SOME
IMMIGRANTS TO LIVE IN POVERTY
AND I HAVE TO UTILIZE MOTELS AS
AS THERE ARE.
PRIMARY ON HOME UNFORTUNATELY SO
THIS IS AB HOW WILL.
ENSURE THAT THOSE FAMILIES THAT
THAT DO LIVE IN THOSE MOTELS ARE
PROTECTED IN ENSURING THAT THE
THEIR INFORMATION IS NOT
PROVIDED OFFER THAT FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
IS YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON ANOTHER
ROUND WITH THE WEATHERMAN GROUP
REPRESENTING NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I SAY NONE IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING SARABYN ON BEHALF
OF CAL CHAMBER JUST WANTED TO
LET AYE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KNOW THAT WITH THE AMENDMENTS --
SET FORTH IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS I'M BEING TAKEN.
I CALTRAIN UBER AND TECHNO AT
WILL BE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
ONE JUST THANK THE AUTHOR
SPONSOR AND STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK THEY'VE DONE ON THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINA'S BAGNOLI
WITH CAL BANKERS I WE SHARE THE
SAME POSITION --
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
AUTHOR IN THE STAFF HAVE DONE
AND THE SPONSORS EYES SPECIALLY
IN THIS CLIMATE WE FELT LIKE IT
WAS IMPORTANT.
TO WORK WITH YOU AND MAKE SURE
WE GOT OFF OF AYE THE
LEGISLATION ON THAT THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT WE SAW SO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TERRY
THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF THEATER OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA NEVADA --
AGAIN IT WOULD PROBABLY BE
SUFFICIENT TO SAY DITTO BUT
BECAUSE IT WAS A LOT OF HARD
WORK PUT INTO THIS BY --
THE SPONSORS OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE AUTHOR STAFF AND WE REALLY
ARE APPRECIATE THE REMOVAL OF
THE MOVIE THEATERS FROM THIS IS
THERE WAS NO HISTORY.
THERE TO INVOLVE THEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'VE REMOVED OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TIM LYNCH ON BEHALF OF SHN
THEATERS OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND WE ALSO OVER MADERA POSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION OR
REMOVING [inaudible]
PRINT.
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU SO WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU AS WELL AS THE THANK
YOU SENATOR BIDEN FOR BRING THIS
IMPORTANT GO FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR WORKING CLEARLY.
A WITH OPPOSITION VERY
EFFECTIVELY OF MID TO REALLY
FOCUS IT ON THE ON THE ISSUE AT
HAND AND UNFORTUNATELY I THINK
WE NEED --
THEN WE NEED THIS TO HELP MORE
THAN EVER IN AND I I JUST THINK
ABOUT --
THEM.
NOT ONLY A THE PROTECTION OF OF
THE OF OUR COMMUNITY BUT YOU
KNOW IF YOU IF YOU'RE.
A NIGHT MANAGER SOME MOTEL AND
YOU HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMING
THAT'S PRETTY INTIMIDATING MANY
OF MANY OF THOSE WHO WORK IN
THOSE WAS ALSO IMMIGRANTS AND
YOU KNOW I THINK CLARIFYING IT
FOR THEM [inaudible]
DO -- IN
ADDITION TO WHAT'S REQUIRED OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THINKS REALLY
IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
STRESS.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU HAS
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I GOT TO TELL YOU THAT WHEN I
READ ABOUT WHAT SOME OF THE
MOTELS WERE DOING AND THE BUS
COMPANIES IT MAKES ME SICK. TO
THINK THAT THAT'S STILL GOING ON
AND IT ISN'T JUST AFTER.
A CHANGE IN LEADERSHIP AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL THIS HAS BEEN
GOING ON AND IT HAS TO STOP.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD FOR
PROVIDING THAT LITTLE BIT OF
MORE OF PROTECTION.
FOR OUR FOR OUR CONSUMERS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
SING NONE SAID VERY MAKE GLOVES
THANK YOU UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS
THE ERA WERE LIVING IN THESE
DAYS I AND TO PROVIDE AN EXTRA
LEVEL OF PROTECTION TO SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS.
UP MEANS THE WORLD TO THEM ITS
OWN I THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US.
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I WILL.
THANK YOU.
MOTION WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND IT IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU CHIU
HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES.
REYES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THAT IS FOUR ZERO TO PUT THAT
OFF HOPSIN A MINUTE OF THAT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO AS WE WAIT FOR MEMBERS COME
BACK AT THE BILL TO PRESENT IN
CENTER LARA'S COMMITTEE.
SO DISCO CAN YOU HANG AROUND FOR
A LITTLE BIT.
SO IF MEMBERS COME BACK.
OPEN THE ROLE GET GET VOTES A BE
BACK AS SOON AS I CAN AND WRAP
UP THE CAN
.
LIFTING THE KLAN SP LET NINETY
FOUR LARA.
CUNNINGHAM CHAU CHIU PULLED IN
THE KILEY.
KILEY NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
YEAH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BACK LOCAL [inaudible]
ALRIGHT SO.
YOU CAN LOOK.
CALL ON SB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
LARA.
CHAO CHIU HOLDEN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
IT IS A LACK ON CALL IS THERE
ANOTHER ITEM OF TO PUT THAT BY
OF A PLACE I BACK ON CALL SYRIA
OTHER ITEM THAT --
SOMEBODY'S ALSO [inaudible]
SHE WAS.
THE DUB.
SO BEGIN TO LOOK UPON S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE DODD
[inaudible]
CHAU.
SAYS ITEM THAT THE FLORA FILE
ITEM THREE SB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
DIED.
CHIU HOLDEN CONSULTS WATCHER
CONSULTS FLETCHER AYE.
THIS ATTACK ON CALL IF WE CAN
LIFT THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM [inaudible] SIX S.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PAN
[inaudible]
CHAU.
CHOW I CHU HOLDEN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
OPUS ABOUT ON CALL.
THAT'S OUT AGAIN --
AND THEN.
THE PRIME NUMBER THAT ASSEMBLY
CHILD WAS OUT ON THIS GO THROUGH
[inaudible]
S..
APART ITEM TO SP TEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WILK.
CHOW CHOW I HOLDEN.
CAN YEAH SURVIVORS WHO
[inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
YOU YOU'RE ALL [inaudible]
YEAH DOT.
NO YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT ALL.
OF SO WE JUST LOOKED AT THAT
CALL.
SO I THINK IT CHAO YEAH LET'S
LET'S LET'S LET'S LOOK THE CALL
AGAIN.
ON A SANDRA LARA'S BILL
[inaudible]
CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU HOLDEN OKAY SO
IT'S S. B. ELEVEN NINETY FOUR IS
THAT OUT [inaudible]
AS OUT [inaudible]
AND THEN.
HAVE YOU AND THE REASON YOU GO
BACK AND GET --
AND THAT.
IT WAS STOLEN HUESO.
OKAY.
SO WHAT ABOUT IT WHICH WILL
REFLECT.
I THINK CONSENT GAUCHO.
CHAO IRON CONSENT HOLDEN.
BUT IT WAS SORT OF ANOTHER
.
AND FOR ME.
SO LET'S LET THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM THREE DODD.
THAT'S S. B. S. B.. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE TWO AYE CHIU AYE
HOLDEN.
PRESTON CALLS WILL PLACE A BET
ON CALL.
NO THAT NO HEAT PEOPLE
[inaudible]
PULLED.
SADDAM FILE ITEM FIVE BECOME
THAT THE CALL SB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR CHIU AYE CHIU
AYE HOLDEN.
I AM NOW A BILLS OUT.
AND THE OTHER BILL THAT TO
MISTER CHIU [inaudible] SIX A
BOTTOM SIX FORD AS REPORTED
TWENTY FOUR PAN.
CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN.
SERBIAN ALSO SQUARED AWAY EXCEPT
FOR MISTER GOLDMAN
.
SO HOLD WELCOME.
HAS A BUSY DAY FOR EVERYBODY IN
VARIOUS COMMITTEES SO START WITH
CONSENT CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I ITEM NUMBER TWO IS S.
B. TEN SEVENTY SEVEN WILK.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS HOLDEN
[inaudible]
HOLDEN I ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE SENATOR DODD
IS ON CALL ME TO LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU I REMEMBER FOR WAS PULLED
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR LARA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I THEN ITEM NUMBER SIX IS
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PAN
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
NINE THANK YOU LOVELY THAT
COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS FOR THE
DAY THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND
WE ARE ADJOURNED